[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في هذه الانتخابات كما
اسلفنا منذ قليل تتنافس مجددا استيس
ابرامز على منصب الحاكم مع الجمهوري براند
كامل سباق لا يهتم به ترامب كثيرا لماذا
لانه يريد ان يخسر الاثنان لو كان ذلك
ممكنا فبراين كانف الحاكم الجمهوري الحالي
رفض الاسراء لترامب خلال الانتخابات 2020
حينما طلب منه وقفه اعتماد تصويت جورجيا
وتظهر استطلاعات الراي ان كان سيحصل على
ولايه جديده في جورجيا رغم كل جهود سيسي
ابره في جورجيا ايضا يوجد سباق على منصب
سكريتير الولايه وهو المنصب المسؤول
مباشره على الاشراف على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بعد سنتين يسال جمهوريه
الى ولايه جديده هذا الرجل ايضا يكرهه
ترامب كثيرا رغم انه من داعميه ترامب
الاقوياء الا ان كل شيء تغير ما انتخابات
عام 2020 حينما طلب منه ترامب ان يفتش على
اكثر من احد عشر احد عشر الف صوت لصالحه
لقلب نتيجه امام ايدل عندها رفض رفنس برجر
طلب ترامب والشاهد ضده ايضا في تحقيقات
الكونتريس بشان اقتحام الكابيتول في
السادس من يناير وتم نشره تسريب للمحادثه
الهاتفيه بينه وبين ترامب
زياده
[موسيقى]